today's topic somebody we've collabed
with i recently put out a video saying i
have cancer if you guys aren't familiar
mediocre tutorial and reviews um someone
you're familiar with as well we talk
offline he runs his youtube channel he's
been on the come up and um yeah he put
out a video today talking about
how he was diagnosed with cancer
testicular specifically
essentially what happened was he felt a
lump down there didn't think much of it
ended up going to the doctor some time
after for his early checkup the doctor
felt the lump but said it's probably
nothing but he said hey listen i still
want to just schedule ultrasound just to
check
scheduled ultrasound there's some
complications there but eventually a
urologist looks at him like yes we're
probably going to have to remove your
right testicle because that lump that
you felt is like a two centimeter uh
mass
and you have testicular cancer so now
he's just coping with the news and how
it's affected him if you guys want i'm
going to link his video in the original
uh and you guys should go check it
i've been thinking about this pretty
often ever since
um
i think when it comes to
men in general
medical checkups are just not encouraged
nor is it something that we do
partially because of the distrust of the
medical system partly because of what we
learn from our heritage
you know and as men just [ __ ] handle
it
but there's a general um
want
to
not go to the hospital even if you're in
pain or dealing with stuff i'll get over
it
and
as i've gotten older i've had
um
the unfortunate experience of having to
witness a lot of people in my life die
from preventable diseases because they
don't get checkups that isn't to say
that had they gone they 100 would have
caught it but it definitely raises your
likelihood
and this issue is compounded for black
folks because of the fact that one
there's a distrust there on top of it
but also because we are much more prone
to certain disease and at younger ages
for example prostate cancer we are
supposed to go get ourselves checked
five to six years before everyone else
is for the recommended times
we're at higher risk for blood pressure
diabetes a lot of these different things
sleep apnea is also similar there's a
bunch of things that we are more at risk
for
and
we're also less likely to go to the
hospital so the mortality rate rises
from there and i've just had to witness
people
you know and people my community lose
pillars
lose
some of the most important members
within that community
to preventable diseases not because of
medications out there not out there not
because the cure wasn't out there not
because they didn't have access to fun
but because they were the type of folks
who just did not like going to the
hospital
we
we already have a lack
of mentors
and
there's like a certain sadness
um both in the fact that i also engage
in that behavior but also knowing that
we are lacking and sometimes we
contribute to that lack within our own
communities
the risks are very real
the effort required to remedy that risk
is very minimal
and we often still don't do it
i'm happy the brother went i'm happy
that it can probably get taken care of
and i'm wishing him the speediest
recovery and i hope it goes well but to
everyone else who's watching at home
please go get yourself checked even it's
your only yearly checkup
even if you're just doing at least a
bare minimum please
because if you won't do it for you
do it for those around you who need you
right for the family that you want to
start or have already started for the
wife that you want to continue to
support the kids that you want to watch
over the mother the family members that
you want to support
the people who need you
this is part of those responsibilities
um
i had a i had a scary experience
i have a hereditary hereditary condition
my dad has it i have it
sleep apnea and now most people are
familiar with this oh you don't in my
family it's very very severe to the
point where
i remember up until like i was like 25
i would just pass
out i'll just pass out on bus buses i
would pass out standing i would pass out
driving it was really uh getting to a
scary point and they're secure there's a
remedy for it there's a machine that you
could use but i was too stubborn because
of my family you just don't do that
you know what happened when you finally
got that matching that machine
yeah i mean it changed my life
what made you make what you made you
take that machine
uh
man you know i'll probably get into
a different day
um
yeah
but you know i don't know like i said
i've just lost a lot of people that are
close to me to preventable stuff and uh
i just don't want it to be the same
situation for you guys so
um
take care of yourselves and i'll
probably let you go because i think you
have a lot you want to say i don't
really have a lot to say
there's not a lot to say it's the right
thing to do
it is the right thing to do
too many people go
and you don't even know why
and you think you're tough until
some [ __ ] happened to you some [ __ ]
scary happened to you
no i got good genes i look young
for cancer
i don't have that good of genes you know
mom had cancer dad cancer
i don't say if i say when
but i get checked
i get checked
it's funny in my community because
especially my community
a lot of haitian people are nurses
work in the health but when it comes to
them they don't they don't do anything
about it they don't talk about it either
we don't talk about it
i don't talk about mental health we
don't talk about health we don't talk
about none of that
we don't take the proper precautions as
well you know in our food and what we
eat
something that
we got to do
i mean i'm nobody for that i'm nobody
to tell you that but at the end of this
choice is yours but
something that you have to do
that's it
oh and
uh
mediocre
god speed bruh
you already know you can always talk to
us when everyone ever so let us know
yeah
just go guys
just go
your loved ones want you to go we want
you to go you want to be okay
i won't kill you to go
nah i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm good
but when
when when it's too late
yeah we wish you would have done
something else now sometimes we're
willing to spend our money on frivolous
things but for things like tests and
thoughts all of a sudden we can't and
look i'm not saying the health care
system is great no
i'm definitely not one to say that but
even for the people who do have
financial access at least often times
still don't go
please
how many more folks do we have to lose
to this kind of stuff also pass that
message on to your kids encourage them
to look into these things
right
yeah that's all man so i don't want to
make this one too long let us know what
you guys think in the comments below if
you have any stories you guys would like
to share but we would love to hear from
you guys on this topic um and yeah as
far as media group mediocre goes we're
wishing you well brother
[Music]
more